mer merci Ono
maintenantivier le maire de Maam une
petite villearne connaissezjà all moi
mazam au Maroc dans cette ville les
enfants de chômeurs ne seront plus
prioritaires à la cantine pour
privilégier les ménages qui n'ont pas le
temps de rentrer à la maison et de
préparer un repas c'est une mesure qui
fait grandement polémique et pour en
débattre on va justement le recevoir et
dites-nous est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
est-ce que c'est une bonne idée ou pas
est-ce une bonne idée ou pas Gill ver tu
peux déjà d déjà dire NON
MERCI non mais c'est normal je suis
d'accord vous êtes d'accord avec moi je
sais pas pas l' faire mais en tout cas
je savais que tu allais dire non savoir
si je suis d'accord avec toi ou pas je
ne sais pas je vais te le dire dans un
instant quand je veux voir Olivier Fabre
mais a priori je préfère à toi allez
c'est parti on
regarde avec l'inflation qui touche le
pays le maire d'une commune située dans
le Tarne a récemment pris une décision
forte augmenter de 20 % le prix du repas
à la contintine de quoi agacer quelques
parents d'élèves c'est énorme pour les
familles qui ont des bas revenus c'est
trop cher mais c'est surtout une autre
mesure ure prise par le maire qui
suscite aujourd'hui la polémique les
enfants de chômeurs ne sont plus
prioritaires pour accéder à la cantine
si l'idée de donner davantage la
possibilité aux parents qui travaillent
de faire manger leur enfants à la
cantine le midi a été salué par certains
d'autres ont vivement critiqué cette
décision c'est pas juste ça nous coince
à la maison alors un mère décide que les
enfants de chôeurs ne sont plus
prioritaires à la cantine est-ce une
bonne
[Musique]
idée Olivier Fabre est avec nous maire
de mazam merci d'être avec nous euh
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
clairement votre mesure bah en fait on
s'est rendu compte à certain moment
qu'on était en surcapacité sur nos nos
cantines scolaires et donc on avait le
choix éventuellement de pousser les murs
et d'embaucher du personnel
supplémentaire et donc d'augmenter les
impôts et c'était pas ce qu'on voulait
faire sinon s'est dit ben peut-être on
peut quand même demander au aux familles
dont les deux parents ne travaillent pas
de reprendre leurs enfants à midi les
semaines c'est pas tout le temps mais
les certaines semaines certains jours où
on a un peu trop d'effectifs sur
certains réfectoires considérant que
quand les deux parents ne travaillaient
pas moi il me semble qu'ils ont le temps
de pouvoir préparer un repas pour leur
enfant à midi de de le reprendre ok donc
voilà Gil ver vous n'êtes pas d'accord
du tout pas du tout et Monsieur le Maire
avec tout mon respect c'est délirant
votre tou avec tout votre respect ça
commence mal toujours avec tout votre
respect vous faites chier les gens non
mais non mais c'est incroyable les
chômeurs sont stigmatisés parce qu'ils
sont hors de la vie sociale et
maintenant vous stigmatisez leurs
enfants en leur interdisant la cantine
parce que vous n'avez pas de place et
puis j'ai relu soigneusement tous vos
propos l' sistana ça suffit il faut
responsabiliser les parents sans emploi
donc derrière cette mesure vous jetez
vous jetez le discrédit sur les pauvres
chômeurs qui voudraient bosser
franchement je vous comprends pas mais
il va vous répondre on juste pas le
discrédit sur les les chômeurs qui
veulent qui veulent bosser ceux qui
veulent bosser j'ai toujours dit s'ils
ont des rendez-vous s'il faut prendre
les enfants on les prend il y a pas de
souci et je vais même vous dire à maamé
on les aide à revenir dans l'emploi
puisqu'on leur réserve lorsqu'ils
retrouvent de l'emploi des places en
crèche donc on aide on est toujours
derrière les les gens qui veulent s'en
sortir les gens qui veulent travailler
en revanche je suis désolé même quand on
est demandeur d'emploi quand on n pas de
travail en France on a un nombre d'aides
extrêmement importants on va citer les
allocations chômage on peut avoir le RSA
les allocations familiales l'Allocation
de rentrée la prime de Noël l'aide au
logement et cetera et cetera
éventuellement des bons alimentaires
donc on a tout ce qu'il faut pour
confectionner un repas basique et on a
le temps qu'il faut pour confectionner
un repas basique moment je suis d'accord
avec Monsieur le ma une fois de plus pas
avec vous ILP les a
monsie trop tu les aides c'est son
propos trop tu les aides ouais B trop
euhon il l'a dit moi je suis je suis
d'accord avec Monsieur le ma parce que
il y a un moment donné tu peux pas te
retrouver comme il a dit pousser les
murs et il y a pas de place l'accueil il
est déploraable dans certaines cantines
tu as parfois un seul un seul
accompagnant pour 30 élèves ou 35 élèves
donc tu peux pas faire le boulot
correctement et vous vous mélangez le
problème s'il y a des s'il y a des
dérogations la personne qui doit aller
chercher du une décoration une
dérogation ils accueillent l'enfant il
est où le problème on fait pas des
enfants pour les mettre à la cantine si
tu ne travailles pas que les deux
parents travaillent pas tu les gardes
avec toi tuas pas fait ton gosse pour le
mettre à la cantine et je vais vous dire
moi je vais même encore je suis encore
plus méchant que lui parce que même
l'étude j'aurais dit non l'étude où tard
ton enfant à l'étude pour
rien sa faire du soutien du soutien
scolaire pas de problème mais si c'est
pour qu' joue dans la cour pendant que
la pendant que la Madame ou Monsieur ils
sont sur les réseaux sociaux chez eux en
train de regarder Instagram les chôurs
il regardent instagam mais tu sais pas
tu sais pas mais c'est pas parce que tu
es chôurs que tu ne peux pas t' dit il
dit churs regard Instagram le moi j'en
connais j'en connais je suis désolé moi
j'ai parlé à un gars qui un voisin à moi
je lui dit moi je m'en fous je payais la
cantine 5 € à l'époque il dit moi
pourquoi tu fais pas comme moi moi je l'
mets à la cantine c'est 50 centimes mais
moi j'ai pas le même revenu que toi donc
pour pour toi tu puisses payer 50
centimes c'est très bien mais moi je
paye 5 € pour ça pour que toi tu puisses
pour que je t'aide mais comme tu ne
travailles pas tu pourrais toi garder
ton enfant chez toi non ça me prend la
tête t moi je regarde les informations
ça crie sa gueule l'après-midi il faut
que j'aille réparé des voitures il avait
des trucs à faire il avait des trucs à
faire mais il ne voulait pas garder ses
enfants donc moi je suis d'accord avec
Monsieur le Maire on fait pas des
enfants pour les à la cantine on
fait des enfants pour les assumer et
s'en occuper et s'il doit aller chercher
du travail il y aura une dérogation il
pourra aller chercher du travail je vois
pas en quoi ça vous pose problème moi ce
qui me pose problème c'est d'avoir un
accompagnant pour 35 élèves et un
accueil déplorable manque d'adsem manque
d'AVS manque de plein de gens dans la
cantine parce qu'il y a des gens qui
pourrai donner à manger à leurs enfants
les garder avec eux le midi puisqu'il
foutent rien de la journée Gill faut pas
fermer les yeux il y a des gens qui ne
foutent rien de la journée et qui se
débarrassent de
le faut pas se cacher ça existe bravo
non non non c'est bon on a déjà de
petites secondes attendez attendez il y
a quelqu'un qui me pose une question il
a une amie à moi très intéressant
Isabelle demande au m si les tarifs de
ces cantines sont calculés au cootient
familial c'està-dire selon les revenus
des parents si oui ça règle le problème
sinon ça mesure est inepte et inique non
alors sur Maam on a pas de de tarif au
ccient familial il y a des tarifs
différents selon la maternelle ou le
primaire mais ensuite c'est le même prix
pour dit votre mesure il y a il y a un
dégressif pour les familles nombreuses
voilà plus 20 % à la rentrée mélange
mélange votre ami mélange on le parle
pas moi j'ai parlé de tarif là on ne
parle pas de tarif on parle de place on
on parle de pousser les murs un moment
donné on peut pas accueillir tout le
monde s'il y a comme ça mon AM c'est
elle a pas ton âge elle a pas mon âge
non un petit peu de respect quand même
mais j'ai beaucoup de respect pour votre
ami mais elle mélange le tarif elle
parle du tarif on parle pas tarif on
parle du manque de
place en ce que explique Monsieur le
Maire c'est que il a un problème de
tarif il a un
[Musique]
problmeéleou
norm élèv est-ce que c'est normal tu as
des écoles où il y a une Assem qui
s'occupe de 30 ou 35 élèves est-ce que
tu trouves ça normal un moment donné il
y a trop de monde dans les cantines
problèmes là
monde toi tu cautionnes toi tu es au
chômage tu discore exprimé là pour le
moment donc je
cautionne c'est la prière fois qu'il est
d'accord avec ver oui c'est vrai je
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure dans les loges
je me disais je vais faire une je vais
faire une verdeise ce soir voilà boness
d'être brillant
vas-y
tu sais bien cher maître vénéré que je
ne vais pas y arriver permettrai pas non
je pense que c'est je comprends très
bien votre volonté de vouloir combattre
la sistana derrière cette mesure et ça
je partage ce sentiment là d'essayer de
réveiller un peu les choses et de faire
en sorte que les gens se prennent en
main ça de ce point de vue-là je suis
d'accord mais je pense juste à l'enfant
et pour moi c'est une mauvaise idée à
cause de l'enfant parce que j'ai peur
ben parce que ne pas aller à la cantine
attends je peux finir ma
pH ne pas aller à la cantine toute la
semaine voir ses copains aller à la
cantine et toi être obligé
d'allerais arum que les enants les
enfants ils ont besoin d'être
copain
er c'est il cherche pas l'idée c'est
[Applaudissements]
pas pas l'idée de combattre la sistana
c'est c'est de c'est de pousser les murs
il y a aussi un problème réel qui est
que tout d'un coup tu as une nana ou un
monsieur qui va s'occuper de 40 gosses
et qui peut pas un seul pour 40 ce n'est
pas possible c'est des pragmatism et
enfin et par ailleurs ce serait ce
serait pourquoi pas moi Mo mon premier
réflexe a été oh mon dieu c'est pas bien
et quand j'ai commencé à lire j'ai
changé d'avis parce qu'effectivement
j'ai vu que si il y a un parent qui a un
rendez-vous professionnel parce que
justement il peut changer de statut on
accue
l'fant m au foyer et que tu acceptes
d'avoir ton enfant à déjeuner alors
c'est stigmatisant pour l'enfant il
mal tu VO bien tu dis n'impor dis quo c
pas dans sa construction il y un moment
donné où il envie
a veut parler non mais déjà je supporte
pas sous-entendu que tous les chômeurs
le sont par plaisir je trouve
insortable les enfants non mais r l'
sentendu les enfants sont extrêmement
dur les un envers les autres il y a du
harcèlement il y a des et quand on dira
que tu ne vas pas à la cantine parce que
tes parents sont pauvres je trouve ça
extrêmement dur et pardon mais là vous
répercute
réperc pas
fortunét
je ne supporte pas que la situation
sociale par B attend la trè B je
supporte pas que la situation sociale
des des parents et une répercussion sur
les enfants et là vous les traitez comme
si les parents étaient étaient des
criminels être chôeur ce n'est pas un
crime je suis désolé ça peut arriver
d'être au chôage et c'est discriminant
pour les ENF Jean-Michel et Monsieur le
ma Monsieur Ma on n pas des brutes sans
cœur ça se passe comment on est une
petite ville si on a un plan sur une
semaine et qu'on voit que on est en
surcapacité on appelle des familles dont
on sait que les deux parents ne
travaillent pas on leur demande de bien
vouloir prendre leur enfant voyez c'est
pas un espèce de tribunal là
les enfants V dire tu es pauvres tes
parents ils sont pauvres il
sont faut arrê avec ça et puis alors
surtout retournons retournons l'histoire
qu'est-ce que je dis imaginez qu'on
fasse l'inverse qu'est-ce que je dis à
des à des des parents don donc qui sont
les deux à travailler je leur dis ben
non je peux pas prendre votre enfant
midi parce que vous êtes pas prioritaire
je fais d'abord passer ceux qui
travaillent pas qu'est-ce que je leur
dis les gens qui travaill qui ont des
petits salaires qui P tout et qui n'ont
aucune aide tu tu veux parler au
DRJ je suis désolé mais compl d'enquête
tu avais raison c'est côté faible ce
évidemment bah oui toi tu oublies tes
couilles à la maison il oublie ton
cerveau excuse-moi ça aucun rapport il y
a pas que les enfants qui dont les
parents sont chôeurs qui qui mangent à
la maison à midi il y a pas queux qui
mangent à midi il y a d'autres enfants
aussi dont les parents travaille qui pr
qui rentre parce que la maman travaille
juste à côté et cetera donc c'est pas
stigmatisant parce que tu manges pas à
midi tu seras déclaré chômeur et puis
comme dit Geraldine les chôurs qui vient
plus que les gens qui travaillent et
puis c'est une question économique tu as
déjà géré une ville toi
non fais confiance à ceux qui gè as
toujours des grandes idées mais tu fais
rien j'ai une question pour
Monsieur bravo
JeanMichel peux poser une question à
Monsieur le Maire oui vous pouvez poser
une question Monsieur le Maire Monsieur
le Maire je vous en supplie dites la
vérité mais y a de ma le ma Monsieur le
Maire vous avez augmenté les tarifs de
20 % et vous avez dit vous-même que vous
en avz marre parce que vous aviez
beaucoup d'impayé écarter les familles
dont les parents sont au chômage pour
vous c'est une sécurité financière vous
faites ça parce que ces pauvres gens
n'ont pas les moyens de payer et vous
les sanctionne financièrement ça c'est
vrai Monsieur le Maire oh non vous
pouvez pas Monsieur le Maire Monsieur le
Maire les yeux dans les yeux ne mentez
pas des enfants de chômeurs on en
accueille encore aujourd'hui c'est dans
les cas où on a un surffectif on leur
demande s jours certaines semaines de
les reprendre ensuite sur les tarifs les
affamés sur sur les tarif moi je vais
rappeler quelque chose parce que là
c'est c'est pas le cas camasame c'est le
cas sur l'ensemble des communes en
France aujourd'hui quand vous avez le
prix d'un ticket de restauration
scolaire en général vous avez au minimum
60 à 70 % du prix qui est payé par le
contribuable çaam un repas ça nous
revient à 12 € entre les ingrédients la
cuisine les gens qui font la cuisine les
gens qui serve et puis le personnel qui
encadre 12 € et c'est facturé un peu
plus de 4 € par repas au aux familles le
reste c'est le contribuable qui le prend
en char un moment il faut arrêter de de
de comme ça de continuer à solliciter
les contribuables enfin ils en pourront
plus au bout d'un moment voyez ce que je
veux dire donc c'est bien probl
financier dans les familles pauvres ce
repas à la cantine parfois champ c'est
le c'est le seul repas de la journée
dont vous allez priver un enfant c'est
ça qui me rend triste non mais on a des
serv on est dans une ville en une fois
taille humaine on des services sociaux
qui connaissent les gens on sait qu'il y
a des situations qui sont extrêmement
difficiles on y fait bien sûr attention
mais je vous garantis qu'il a aussi des
situations on considère et à juste titre
que les parents ont la capacité du fait
qu'ils ne travaillent pas ils ont le
temps de préparer un repas basique un
moment il faut aussi les mettre devant
le responsab j'ai une question pour
Monsieur le
Maire j'ai question pour Monsieur le
Maire vous dites qu'il a pas assez de
place mais c'est pas place ou pas de
nourriture place on peut aussi faire
question d'horaire il y a des enfants
qui peent manger à 11h à midi à 1h à 1 à
14h c'est questions d'horaire moi je
mangis des fois dis-moi tu vas enô
histoire non moi je vais bouffer là
[Applaudissements]
15 tu m
14 non je suis au deè je suis de tu vas
ens B non j'ai réservé à 16h le resto
impossible impossible c'était où cétait
où j'allais en mat ou j'allais au resto
j'ai réservé à 16h on a une table pour 4
je te jure impossible ta bondé bourrééta
bourré j vais au trè service je te dis
vous faites deux trois services mais de
trois services ça veut dire quand les
enfants sont sortis qu'ils ont mangé
avant qu'ils reviennent en cours il faut
du personnel en plus pour les surveiller
donc vous multipliez V personnel si vous
écoutez fair le petit
d P tu vas tu vas en cours non le petit
c'est une solution je prop des solutions
ça va ouais tu baises d'un ton
he hein ça va hein mais ce qui est
épuisant en fait c'est que ici on a des
noms en fait d'idéologie en fait juste
par démagogie par posture tu dis ça pour
Gill
verd n on est on est on est dans le camp
du Bien on est les gentil Gill Verdes
comme d'habitude s de démagogie
larmoyante comme ça donc on est dans le
camp du Bien voilà et vous vous êtes
dans le concret vous êtes dans le réel
vous êtes là vous vous devez vous devez
verrouiller votre budget vous devez
faire bouffer les les enfants vous devez
rendez comptes et vous êtes et vous êtes
là vous êtes c'est pragmatique et nous
on est juste sur les plateaux télé là on
devise comme ça ah non c'est pas bien
faut sanner les pauvres vous êes
S mais qui te dit que tous les chômeurs
sont pauvres me il y a S discussion en
même temps là tu t'es cru dans et en
plus moi je trouve que à titre personnel
je trouve que c'est extraordinaire
d'avoir son enfant à l'heure du déjeuner
ça ça tisse le lien on parle avec lui
comment s'est passé sa matinée on fait
un bilan ça dure pas non plus 8h un
déjeuner il faut pas exagérer donc je
sais pas pourquoi toi tu vas être
bientôt papa j'espère que tu seras
content d'avoir ton papa entre midi et
de hein en
enfant oubli je je trouve
ça je trouve ça facile franchement non
mais ça va être un très bon papa lui je
trouve ça facile de sanctionner les
pauvres la vraie question qu'onit poser
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait plutôt que
d'exclure et de discrimin les enfants
pvres les enfants de famille P y a plein
d'autes moyens de le faire fait qu'on
fait l'argent pas les d'Er me c'est pas
un mec qu' faut embaucher mais je vois
pas ton ta phrase écoute
dansend mes m pas
la je rigole non mais si s'il ne mangeit
pas à la cantine parce que le parents
sont chur non mais je suis désolé trs
fait ça parce qu'il est inhumain parce
qu'il est méchant parce qu'il en ve de
monur c'est il devrait le système avec
tout l'argent public qui existe on
devrait trouver les les moyens pour
payer les
G l'argent public il existe pas dans les
mairies dans les pees communes l' ni
milliard on on donne une dernière fois
banana SP oui allez banana attends
attends banana banana e frère tu sais
que ta teté n'a jamais été aussi
longue sur ma vie tu as 35 cm de teté
non mais sans déconner tu peux pas et le
casque qui s'arrête Hal frère non mais
frère avec la Pecou et tout tuas j'adore
c'est que ça te va hyper bien merci non
sans déconner pas fa c'est gentil pour
une fois que vous me complimentez je je
que je te trouve hyper beau tu as une
beauté qu'on a pas encore
vu différent Monsieur le Maire vous
allez voir le regard d'un enfant oh oh
là
là assumezle assumez-le ah
oui le regard d'un enfant qui à qui
affamé à qui à qui
amis à qui ses amis vont dire ah toi tu
mange pas à la cantine enfant de chôur
c'est ça que vous voulez
à répondz même pas on va regarder
le 32%
estce
les gens du av mararqué chez vous que
j'étais du côté du nom voilà évident ça
me rassure les gens merci Monsieur Merci
monsieur le Maire en tout cas d'avoir
été avec nous merci à vous merci merci
Monsieur le Maire vous avez Jean-Michel
mer aussi à côté c'est très
sympa tu as du cœur tu as du cœur je
suis au bout de ma vie moi euh